- I probably wouldn't
listen to, who is this?
Backstreet Boys?
- These guys look 30.
(light electronic music)
- Right now I'm like,
so One Direction, so.
- I'm a One Direction fan.
- I don't know any of their names.
- Me neither.
- But these were, like, probably like,
the biggest stars of like, their time.
- My mom was all over this.
- This reminds me of One
Direction right here,
but maybe One Direction
stole this from them.
- I actually like the song.
- It's a good song, it's catchy.
- And the guy in the front is super cute.
- We should like, Google him
and see what he looks like now.
- I know.
- The denim on denim on denim on denim
has not come back yet.
- I hope it never comes back.
- I think these guys set the tone
for a lot of these boy bands.
- Isn't Justin Timberlake in this band?
- Justin Timberlake is my favorite.
- You are a major R&B
star now because of this.
- I feel like their
dancing is kind of better.
- This one's my jam.
- Their heart's been tearing up,
but their like, at this local gym.
- There's more, like, material things
being shown off in music
videos now these days.
- I could totally see
myself being a fangirl.
- Oh, this song.
- They're not supermodel-y.
- I feel like this is
like, a wedding song.
- I actually do kind of like it.
- I like, love this song.
- Sounds very heartfelt, oh
wait, here comes the chorus.
- Oh, I know this song, I do.
- I swear I will get on one bended knee,
I will stand outside your
house in the pouring rain.
- This would never be on the radio today
because it's, like, so good.
- Yeah, they don't play
this stuff anymore.
- Nowadays they talk about ass and tits.
This song, they actually
talk about loving a girl.
- There just, like, isn't
music like this anymore,
but I wish there was.
- Who's in 98 Degrees?
- I can't think of a single person.
- Isn't that Jessica Simpson's ex-husband?
- Oh, Nick Lachey.
- I've heard of him, but I guess
I didn't realize he was in a band.
- I didn't know he sang.
- Why is everybody's pants so baggy?
- Even these shirts, so '90s,
nobody wears like that anymore, really.
- And those little earrings.
- It's a cute song, but, nah.
- I've never heard of Hansen.
- You haven't?
- Oh my gosh, they're so young.
- I think they're all brothers.
- Aw, that's awesome.
- I don't get it.
- I don't know what's going on,
but they look like they're
having a good time.
- This might be my favorite
music video so far,
like, this looks like a lot of fun.
- It's kind of cute, I mean,
where are their parents though?
- Yeah, I'm pretty sure
once they hit puberty
and those voices drop, I'm like, yeah.
- Oh yeah, their money when whoo.
- Definitely heard of the Backstreet Boys.
- This guy looks like Aaron Carter.
- Yeah, right?
- Oh.
- I Googled him recently,
and he does not look bad.
- That like, drum beat
of like, the boy bands,
it's all the same.
- I love the outfits, though,
like the girls' outfits.
- Maybe those are Spice Girls.
- I think I'm more of a
New Kids On The Block,
but actually, I kind of
like this song better,
so I'm really conflicted right now.
- We know this song, they
play this at every graduation.
- It would be faster now.
- But they got some good voices.
- Oh, he's into it.
- You can see the soul
coming out of his neck.
- Like, they show vulnerability, you know?
- I'm digging the coordinated outfits.
- Their fashion is dope, I like it.
- I miss songs like this, I could cry.
- I think children should listen to this
rather than, like, what's playing now.
- That's so true.
- We need more of this.
- Yeah, we need more of this.
- The '90s boy bands,
overall, were like, great.
- I didn't know a lot about '90s boy bands
till watching this, but if I grew up
back in the day, I feel
like I'd be really into it.
- I do wish that music videos now
were like '90s music videos, or at least,
the songs were like '90s songs,
because everything is so smooth sounding
and just chill, and not so much,
like, of the derogatory lyrics.
- They definitely catered and
dedicated their songs to girls,
making girls feel good about themselves.
They'll definitely be remembered forever.
(electronic dance music)